joining me now matt walsh host of the
matt wall show
matt uh there's a political a word for
this political system which the
government controls
uh corporate actions and they're trying
to tell us that this is
just we don't control the big tech
companies
what does this tell you yeah i like how
jenn saki just
threw that in there oh yeah we're
working with facebook like hold on a
second what do you mean you're working
with facebook
there's supposed to be a private company
and and for the surgeon general to be to
be talking as he did today
about how we're going to label
misinformation as some sort of
public health threat what that means is
we're going to label speech
as a physical threat i thought i was
thought it was interesting that the
the surgeon general said that he was
talking about misinformation he said
well
uh you know there's misinformation for
example that made people resistant to
masks well hold on a second
the surgeon general's office was the one
who said a year a year ago we shouldn't
wear masks
fauci said a year ago we shouldn't wear
masks this just shows you the problem
that
you know a year ago if you had said
let's wear masks
that's labeled misinformation now you
say the opposite and that's a
misinformation
because the government they are the the
scientific authorities and whatever they
say is now the scientific truth
apparently
now the you mentioned the surgeon
general let's let the folks hear more
from this bright light
they can identify people who are super
spreaders of misinformation
and limit the information that they
share number two they can
take the data that they have that tells
them us how much
misinformation is really spreading who
it's affecting they can share that
publicly and transparently
with researchers uh matt
publicly and transparently i got to tell
you
i think they are killing uh the push for
the vaccine
with these types of heavy-handed tactics
i think it's making people more
skeptical not less
yeah well i i think in general with the
vaccine you know
the thing is that everybody in the
country knows
that the vaccine is out there they know
all the basic facts about it they know
they can go get it if they want to
right so i tend to respect people's
intelligence and i tend to think that uh
number one whether you get a vaccine or
not none of my business it's your
decision
number two if you've decided not to get
it you have your reasons and that's it
so there's probably not a lot that can
be said to change your mind i mean you
could bring olivia rodrigo up or
a pop star up there maybe maybe there
will be someone who said you know what
i'm
i wasn't sure about the vaccine but now
that olivia rodrigo said something i
think i'll do it maybe that'll happen i
doubt it
but i agree with you if you are going to
convince anyone these sorts of tactics
aren't going to do
it because it just makes it seem like
you've got something to hide number one
and number two
you know why do you have to force it on
us like this if it's uh if it's really a
good idea to begin with why can't you
just give us the fact maybe they should
i think they should just open a bureau
of disinformation
they should just have they should just
actually institutionalize their
fact checking at the white house through
big tech let's not go through the
formality of
of saying you're working but just do it
yourselves at this point matt
thank you